welcome to simply learn and Matt plot
library my name is Richard Kirchner with
the simply learned team that's WW simply
learn comm get certified and get ahead
today we're going to study the Met plot
library and the Python code so what's in
it for you
what is Matt plot library types of plots
plotting graphs and sub graphs adding a
graph inside a graph graph parameters
title label legend line graphs line
types color and transparency canvas grid
and axes range 2d plots scatter step bar
fill between radar chart histogram
contour image 3d surface image and then
we'll hit a practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is Matt plot
library Matt plot library is an open
source drawing library which supports
rich drawing types it is used to draw 2d
and 3d graphics and there are so many
packages in the Matt plot library we're
gonna cover the basics and there are so
many packages that sit on top of the map
flight library that we can't even cover
them all today but we'll hit the main
one since you have a good understanding
of what the Matt plot library is and
what the basics can do you can
understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of Matt
plot library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
that you can see here that we'll go into
we have the bar chart the histogram or I
use a lot of histograms and my stuff
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph let's start plotting them and
to do this I'm going to be using Jupiter
notebook you can use any of your Python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the Jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff that's so
visual and in our Jupiter notebook which
opens up in this case I'm using Google
Chrome you can go up here to new and
we'll create a new Python 3 and set that
up if you're not familiar with Jupiter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that and
you look at any of our tutorials they
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up
Jupiter and anaconda I myself used you
put her through anaconda in fact let's
go ahead and open that up and just take
a look with it see what that looks like
you can see your anaconda navigator if
you installed it it will automatically
install the jupiter notebook and it also
installs a lot of other things i know
some people like the QT console for
doing Python or spider I've never used
them I actually use notepad plus plus as
one of my editors and then I use the
Jupiter notebook a lot because it's so
easy to have a visual while I'm
programming an even simple script in
Python I'll take it from the Jupiter
notebook and then do a save as you know
it's going your file and you can
download as a Python program so that
will download it as an actual Python
versus the ie Python that this saves it
as so let's go ahead and dive in and see
we got going here let's go ahead and put
Matt plot library tutorial and I'm gonna
turn this cell into a markdown so
doesn't actually run it we can see it
has a nice little title there that's all
Jupiter notebook and then from Matt plot
library let's import PI lab back one and
then let's go ahead and just print go
lab and the version let's go ahead and
run this so we're gonna import our PI
lab module from the mat plot library and
we find out the word version 1.1 5.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably I was reading article
that said the number one thing that
python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're gonna graph
things I think we need some data to
graph so we're gonna import numpy as in
P now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us and there is a lot of
ways to create data but we're going to
use the in p9 space so we're gonna
create a numpy array and the right way
you read this is we're going to create
numbers between 0 and 10 and we're going
to create 25 of these numbers so we're
just going to divide that equally up
between 0 and 10 and if we have x
coordinates we should probably have some
y coordinates
we'll do something simple like X times X
plus 2 let's just take a look we're
gonna print X and print Y let me go
ahead and run this and let's see we got
going on here so we have our x
coordinates which is 0 0.4 0.8 3 etc and
you can look at this as an XY plot so
where we have 0 we have 2 where we have
point 4 1 6 we have 2 point 1 7 and just
as a quick reminder we're gonna do print
in PR ax comma Y dot reshape 25 comma 2
and the reason I want to do this is I
want to show you something here a lot of
times a program returns X comma Y and
it's an array of X comma Y X comma Y X
comma Y and so when you're working with
the pie plot you have to separate it out
and reshape it so if I start off with
pairs like this I can reshape them if I
know there's 25 pairs in there I can
switch the 2 and the 25 and this is kind
of goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape
so I'm gonna reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25 and if I run that you'll see I
end up with the same output as the X Y
the two different arrays in here and
this is important that we want X and y
separate again that's all numpy stuff
but it's important to understand that
this is a format that Matt plot library
works with it works with an array of X's
and they should match your array of Y's
so each one has 25 different entities in
it and then for our basic plotting of
this data it only takes one command to
draw graph of this data and so we use
our from up here we imported pylab you
take our pylab and the key net lender
there is plot for plotting a line and
then we want our x coordinates and our Y
coordinates we'll throw in our and the
are simply means red so we can draw the
line in red let me go and run that you
can actually switch this around if you
wanted to do different there's B for
blue we have a lot of fun yellow hard to
see yellow there we go but we'll go
ahead and stick with red run and when
you're doing presentations with these
trying
be consistent you know if the business
and the shareholders send you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph trying
to be consistent use green for profit
for money you don't have to necessarily
use green but it's whatever they're
using whenever the companies using
trying to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around and every time
one graph has red for loss and one graph
has blue for loss that gets really
confusing so make sure you're consistent
in your graphs and your coloring and
something to know because we're gonna
cover this in a minute this is your
canvas size so we have a canvas here and
what we're gonna do next is we're going
to look at sub graphs okay so let's take
our pylab and create a sub plot okay one
of the things also to know when we're
working with the mat plot library I'm
not sending when I do this this is my
drawing canvas the pylab so once i've
imported the pylab I'm drawing my images
on they're very important to know and
with the sub plot we're gonna give it
some different values and we're gonna
represent by rows columns and indexes
and let's do one to one so it's gonna be
the first row second column and the
index is like you can stack your graphs
and things like that we don't worry too
much about indexes but rows and columns
so we want to go ahead and use Row 1 and
column 2 and if we're going to have one
object we should probably have two but
before we do that we have to plot data
on to the subplot so the order is very
important and we're going to stick with
our X comma Y and let's do this we're
gonna add in a third parameter here
remember we did red we're gonna add
shorthand - - 4 - lines so this plots
the data into row 1 column 2 and if
we're going to do that let's do up
another one hi lab subplot and if we're
going to do Row 1
let's do column 2 and index 2 and this
time we're gonna have G for green and
this denotes a style and if we're gonna
set up our pylab subplot there we go I
laugh we gotta go ahead and plot that pi
lab plot and instead of XY we want y
comma X oops I messed up this is in the
wrong spot there we go move then down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells at the
row column and index and the pie plot
tells at what data in this case we
switched them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that and you'll see it takes this
canvas splits it in two and now we have
two different graphs and we have the red
one with dash lines and we have the
green one which is has little stars
going up and if we take this and let's
just just for fun let's change this and
run that with an index of one it puts
them both on the same index it also
gives me a warning because it's a
strange way of doing two subplots
there's this depreciated there's another
way to do it but most people just ignore
that warning because it's not gonna go
away anytime soon now that's using the
same setup what happens if we do instead
of this let's change the column on here
and find out what happens and if we do
the column
we didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep her
column as to and let's change the row on
the second one to two and run that and
you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together it can cause of some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where I made some changes I said Row two
and look what happens when I change to
column 2 so I now have Row two column
two index 2 let's squish it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does there's all kinds of
different things you really have to just
play with these numbers till you get a
handle on them because you know we get
to repeated 164 times according to can
bridge University if it's completely new
to you and you can see right here where
3 run there we go but you can see it
takes a little bit sometimes to play
with these and get the numbers right
open to hit the wrong one that's why
let's go 3 there 3 there run there we go
now it's overlapping so I have this
doubled over here on the right for now
we'll just go ahead and leave this with
the where we have column and row 2 in
the two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side-by-side and then as
we just saw we were flashing through
them we can put them on top of each
other and let me just highlight that and
copy it down here paste it down there
and here we have one two one and then
we'll do one two one also for this one
and that puts the two subplots directly
on top of each other gives us that
warning and you can see we now have two
different sets of data graphed on top of
each other I didn't also see how it did
the indexes since one of them is from 0
to 10 that's the green one on the x-axis
and the other one is from 0 to 10 on the
y-axis so it took the greatest value of
either one and then use those as a
shared value so let's next look at
operator description and we'll go ahead
and turn the cell into a markdown and
run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember I talked about
the canvas earlier I briefly mentioned
it we're gonna look a little bit more at
the canvas later on but that's what the
figure is fit we're gonna add axes so
we're going to initialize a subplot add
this
plot in rows and columns and all kinds
of different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and I want you to notice
that there's fit which is the actual
canvas in the matplotlib rarey and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals P ot subplot earlier we did the
pylab so let's go ahead and import PI
plot from that plot library and we're
going to do it as PLT you'll see that a
lot that's really the standard in the
industry is to call it P LT just like
pandas is PD and numpy array is in P
certainly you could import it as
whatever you want but I would stick to
the standards and we're going to do the
same graph as we did above with the PI
lab but with the PLT so if it looks
familiar there's reason we're doing this
because we want to show you how the
figure part works and working with the
canvas goes what we're gonna do the same
plot as we did before and we'll call it
fig and we're going to set that equal to
plot figure so there's our figure or a
canvas on there and let's create a
variable called axes and we're gonna set
that equal to fig dot at axes and in
this we're gonna control the left-right
the width the height of the canvas from
0 to 1 and so we can go ahead and put
some stuff in there I got point five
point one point eight point eight so
when you're looking at this this is a
zero to one or you could say 50 percent
10 percent 80 80 percent
what's the control it's gonna control
your left and your right along with the
width and the height so the width and
the height we're gonna use 80% and we're
gonna have like a little indent on the
left and the right and this would look
familiar from above xes plot X comma Y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we recreated the same graph
let's keep it uniform oppositely helped
so if I use a X I asked a set of ax es I
don't know where that came from but this
looks identical to the one we had up
above so here's our axes plot X comma Y
of red same graph same set up but this
time we've added a variable equal to the
figure add axes
so our plot figures our canvas our axes
is what
working in and then our actually stop
plot X comma Y and again we can draw sub
graphs we put that down here just like
we did before in a little different tone
Jason here we're going to fig axes equal
PLT dot subplots and in here it's going
to be the number of rows we're gonna do
one row and columns equals two so if you
remember before that's what we did we
had one row at two different graphs on
it we're gonna do the same thing but
know how we did this here's our figure
or our canvas and our axes we're gonna
create actually two different axes we're
gonna create row one column two and so
axes is an array of information so we
can simply do for those two acts in axes
this is I look familiar ax dot plot
we're gonna do X comma Y we'll go ahead
and make it read keep everything looking
the same remember nice uniform graphs
everything looks the same and if we go
ahead and run this you'll see we get two
nice side by side graphs so just as we
had before the same look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
two three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's even
make it a little bit more interesting
will do in rows equals to two and you
can see down here we're gonna get in the
tributary X's try and just crunch
everything together so does it have a
limit how much stuff I can put in one
small space that's important to know you
can fix that by changing the canvas size
which we'll look at in just a minute
there's other ways to change it on here
but here we go we can do in rows two and
columns equals one you can see two nice
images right above each other go back to
the original one row two columns
side-by-side left to right and we can
also draw a picture or graph inside
another graph and that's kind of a fun
thing to do it's important to note that
we can layer our stuff on top of each
other which makes for a really nice
presentation so let's start by a fig
create another figure so we're going to
start over again with our canvas we set
that equal to P Ltd figure
so there's our new canvas yeah let's do
excuse we'll call it actually it's one
and two axes one equals fig ad axes
remember this from earlier and this here
similar numbers we use before saying how
big this axes is this figure and the
axes is so this is going to be the big
axes and let's do axes two equals
another figure ad axes and then 0.2 0.5
0.4 0.3 and if we're gonna do this they
need data on them so let's go ahead and
plot some data on our axes so axes one
plot will make this simply X comma Y
comma make it red and then let's go AXYZ
true dot plot and let's reverse them y
comma X comma green there we go
doing what I told you not to do you
shouldn't be swapping axes around and
plotting your date in five different
directions because confusing let's go
ahead and run this and see what this
looks like and then let's talk a little
bit about this we talked about the point
two point five point four point three
let me just grab the annotation for that
that's left-right width and height so we
have in here that this is going to be
left right so here's our left is 0.1 in
0.5 we you know what let's just play
with this a little bit what happens when
I change this to 0.1 moves it way over
to the left so there's our 0.1 so we can
make this point for run that there we go
so you can see how you can move it
around the branches on here oh point to
0.5 is the left so that's our right so
see what happens we do point oh let's
make this point one that actually is
they headed down a left right I thought
this was wrong it's actually how far
from the bottom I switch that on here
bottom there we go so we had here on
this we could go ahead and put that back
to 0.5 and run that and this is 0.3
let's make this point 3 also and that is
the width and then of course there's the
height that we can make that really tiny
so you just do 0.2 let's run that and
you can see it changes the height on
there we make it even smaller 0.2 by 0.2
and as you can see you can get stuck
playing with this to make it look just
right it could sometimes take a little
bit certainly once you have the settings
if you're doing
presentation you try to keep a uniform
unless it doesn't make sense for the
graph you're working on try to keep the
same color as the same position and the
same look and feel and I mentioned
earlier we can adjust the canvas size so
this is from earlier I just copied it
down below we're gonna reap lot the same
data we've been looking at and what we
can do is we can change the figure size
to sixteen by nine let me run that to
show you what that looks like so it
fills the whole screen and then if you
are normally when you're working on the
screen you don't worry too much about
this but we can set the DPI
to 300 run that there goes this is your
dots per inch and if you are doing an
output of this and you're printing a
hard copy you want the higher quality I
would suggest nothing under 300 if it's
a professional print you might get a
little less than that but whenever I'm
doing professional graphics and putting
them out on something 300 dots per inch
is kind of the minimal on there you can
go a lot higher too but keep in mind the
higher you get the more memory it takes
the more lag time and the more resources
you use so usually 300 is a good solid
number to use your dots per inch and you
can see enjoys a nice it draws a nice
large canvas here which is sixteen by
nine and then the DPI is 301 here's it's
a little higher quality and just out of
curiosity I wonder how long it takes to
draw something double that size 600 and
you can see here we're at 600 dpi it's
gonna take a while there it goes
just because it's utilizing a lot more
graphics on there and let me just go
back to the 300 will actually do let's
do a 100 you're not gonna see a
difference on this because it is
web-based graphics are pretty low and up
here you saw I did this with the plot
figure this works the same if I do
figure AXI subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axis plot
X comma Y come on we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this maybe should
get almost the same thing here here's
our X's on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the DPI let me take this
all out you just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this well the things we do is we
can set a title for the AXI so actually
set title you'll see right here since
they put this on the axes it's the main
title for the whole graph and if you're
gonna have a title you should also label
so we can label our X label and we can
set our Y label in this case we're just
gonna call it X&Y
keep it nice in uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
X label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our X Y and then we
run that and of course we can also do a
per size limit so you see what's going
on a little better so here we have X
label X if you come down here you'll see
our X label and our Y label we can of
course change this to X label you change
this to Y be whatever you want on here
of course and our title graph there we
go
run so here we have a title a graph our
Y label and our X label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax legend label 1
label to up here it's a format for it
but let's go down here and actually use
it I'm going to do two different plots
we're gonna have axes plot x by x times
x squared and x cubed and if I run this
you'll see it puts two nice graphs on
the set up on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we actually do axis
since we have the two plots legend and
on here we've created an array and we
have y equals x squared y equals x cubed
you can actually put this as whatever
you want those are just strings and then
location two and let's go ahead and run
this and see what that looks like and
you can see it puts a nice legend on the
upper left-hand corner
location - we can do location three and
run it and it drops it down to the
bottom location one can remember where
that's at
there we go upper right so each one of
these is a number that refers to the
different locations on the screen zero
kind of have to play with them or let
them up to remember where they're at but
they do work it just kind of moves
around depending on where you want your
legend data on there so on this section
we cover the title of the graph the Y
labels and legends this is we're getting
into some starting to look really fancy
here so we now have something we can
actually put out you'll see the title
the graph looks a little fuzzy so I
might in a web setup put the DPI up a
couple notches maybe put it at 200 100
might work fine just so that's something
to notice on here when you're playing
with these different things
we had our subplots dpi equals all let's
do 200 and see what that looks like so
you can see it now is a lot clearer it's
also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch so the next section is
let's look at some graph features we
look at line color transparency size and
a few more things on here and oops I
forgot the main title so we have our
figure in our axes equals our plot and
subplots and I go ahead and do a DPI
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see let's
go ahead and do three plots on here
we'll do X by X plus one so it's just
going to be a straight line plot X plus
X plus 2 and axis dot plot X X plus 3
this looks like we're doing nearest
neighbor set up or showing how it
located data putting your lines on there
between the nearest neighbors there we
go
so it draws a nice little graph with
three lines on it one of the things we
can do is we can control the Alpha on
this you can actually see the when they
did these lines it automatically pulls
in different colors for your set up so
some automatic automatic things going on
in there and a lot of times we do that
comma R or we're going to do color
equals red
another notation on here let's go ahead
and run this now we have a bright red
line down there and with the map plot
library you're not limited to red you
can also use the one of many different
color references as you see here with
pound sign 1 1 5 5 DD which just is just
blue and we can do the same thing with
another color on here which it turns out
to be green I can just as easily do this
green blue there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what I want to do is I want to
make this what's called the Alpha on
this and we're gonna set this equal to
0.5 so this is half way see-through when
I run this and it's almost gonna look
pink as you can see through it and let's
change this just a little bit just to
make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because I plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha I'm halfway through so let's go
ahead and do this alpha equals 0.5 and
you know what instead of squaring it
let's take it to the 0.5 power that'll
be kind of interesting to see what that
does well just go to keep it squared
there we go and run that and let's go
back and look at this work crosses over
and the first thing you see right here
is on the blue it's kind of light blue
now you can see how the two colors add
together you'd almost a purple on there
so I can clearly see where the red
crosses the blue line and then the green
just blanks it over because I didn't do
any opaqueness no alpha on there so this
is great if you have lots of data that
crosses over and you need to be able to
track those lines better I'm go ahead
and do this point five I'll run that
oops I did equals 0.5 let me go ahead
and run that and so you can see right
here now you can easily see the red line
how it crosses a green and the blue down
here and if we want to we can do this as
the default is one is solid so we can
change this all to 0.8 let me just do
that oops 58 eight there we go run up so
Musti hit a wrong button there let me
try that again
get rid of a bracket and let's go ahead
and run that and we come down here look
at this you can still see where it
passes behind them but the green
dominates and the blue dominates because
we're now at eighty percent instead of
50% when you can do less that's kind of
fun although at some point the lanes
kind of fade so 0.5 is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at 0.3 and you can easily see where
they cross over and just like you can
play with the colors we can play with
line width and you know let's do let's
try dpi 100 and see what that looks like
on my screen it goes 100 and we'll go in
just take our ax plot let's do 4 of
these lines just to see how they look
next to each other real quick here there
we go
if I run this they should all appear the
same but I make Li does different colors
on there so let's do color equals blue
forgot my excitation marks there we go
we'll go ahead and just make these all
blue just for purposes of being nice and
uniform and then what I want to do is I
want to do the line width width equals
0.25 down here let's do equals 1 about
1.5 and this do one just make this equal
to 2 let's see what that looks like and
we do that you can see it goes from a
very thin line 0.5 a 1-hour 1.5 and 2
which is twice the width of the one and
if we're gonna do different sizes we had
different colors we had our alpha scheme
let's take this whole thing here let's
paste it down here and do another one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles
something no here you can actually
abbreviate this with LW so line width
can also be point let's just do
everything point two and let's set up a
line style we'll do the first one dashes
and let me just paste that down here so
I'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed we
can do a dash dot whoops us to the dash
here add a colon here there we go and
there's a lot of different options we
look at a few more as we go down four
different ways of highlighting data but
when you look at this we have everything
as a line width of two and now we have a
straight line we have a dashed line or a
dash and a dot line there another thing
we can add on here is we're gonna do
here's our axe plot and we did X let's
do X plus 4 so there's right on the top
a new color black line with 1.5 so it's
a smaller line and we're going to take
the line and we're gonna set dashes so
look I've changed some of the notation
here for my line of my axe plot so I can
set my line comma equal to ax plot and
then I can change the line settings this
way and when I run this you run that on
here you'll see the five ten fifteen ten
creates a series of dashes that are
varied in length link in this case they
alternate between a short - and a long -
we can play with these numbers curiosity
always has me what happens when you play
with the numbers just to see what they
look like let's do this let's paste this
down here I'll do two of these just
because they're kind of fun to play with
and let's change this from ten to three
and we're gonna change this one from 15
to 4 and let's run that and you can see
the difference is in the lines it's very
a little bit confusing on there because
I forgot to change the lines are all on
top of each other so let me change that
really quick here and let's run that and
now you can see here's our original dash
line alternating when I change these
numbers on the second one the very end
value to three you can see now we have
the dashes of five let's see I'm gonna
guess this as a - as a 5 skip 10 dashes
of 15 skip 3 and then it goes back to
the beginning dashes 5 dashes skip 10 15
dashes skip 3 and of course the last one
we just switched up a little bit it
looks a lot more uniform because I'm
using two sets of ten or if I did
something like this and change it to 30
that really becomes pronounced as far as
the distances between them and instead
of 4 let's go let's put 30 here also 30
thirty there we go really pronounced on
that one let's look at one more
important group for plotting our data
and in this we're gonna here's our plot
we started with with the X plus 1 X plus
2 X plus 3 you did it in blue on this
one's for different blue lines and this
property we want to add the actual plots
so you can see where the plots are on
the graph and for that we might have our
curt equals 0 and if we run this lets
see it puts a dot for each of these and
there's 25 dots because we have 25 X
values so we actually have 0 and each of
the different values of XY are then
plotted here with the dots and we don't
want to just limit ourselves to dots
gonna also do plus sign that's another
option dots is most common I'll actually
like the dots the best well if we do the
plus sign means he puts a nice
crosshairs or a plus sign on there and
we can do a marker there's a number of
different markers you can use and I
think this one was it s is another one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one s for square o for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably of these
markers another one is number one so if
we run that you'll see we now have these
little hatch marks and let's take all
this just go with the Oh on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second was to marker or size
equals to change that to five and run
that and you can see here it's a nice
little tiny dot versus this is
interesting because it said to I thought
it would be bigger but if you do 0.5
it's even smaller and let's just do 10
to see what that looks like
run that looks huge so marker size a lot
of these are dependent on the DPI and
the setups there's things that switch
around as far as the way the size shows
up you got to be a little careful when
you change one setting it can change all
the other markers and then let's take
our square on here and we'll do we had
markers size we also have marker face
we'll set that equal to red of course we
I mean change that so it's up one knotch
will run that whoops must have mistyped
something on here and i did its marker
face color equals red and so when i run
that you can now see i have the squares
on there with the marker face color of
course we can mix and match these come
down here we'll make this instead of
let's make this plus seven and we'll
make this size 15 marker face color
equals and we'll do what green just
because there we go run very hard to
actually see what's going on they're
still 25 dots they kind of overlap as
you can see they print them over each
other and of course if we really wanted
to make it look horrible
we could just make that really huge
generally though you want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go
that's too small to even see the face so
for you start to see the face on there
around four and maybe an eighth eighth
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered opaque
with our alpha setting on there give us
some nice pastels you see how they
overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line width different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all out you can
combine all these so you can have our
line
with equals two line styles - you can
bring this down here also to the markers
and then we added markers in just
standard a circle a plus sign the square
a little tick which uses a 1 then we had
a marker size and a marker color face
and we combined those you see we get a
nice different series representations we
also briefly mentioned color or you
didn't have to use like in here we used
color black in some place up here and
have to find it we use the actual number
for the color as opposed to I change
them to written blue so you give very
precise on the color if you have a very
specific color set that you need to
match your website or whatever you're
working on all those are tools in the
map plot library so we have one more
piece to formatting the graph so we want
to show you and then we have two big
sections we're gonna go over the
different graphs that they have along
with a challenge problem so let's go in
the last section we're going to look at
is limit so we're going to limit our
data so this first part is going to
paste in there we're gonna create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're gonna do a figure size at 10 comma
5 this should all look familiar now
since we've done a number of them and
we're gonna go ahead and plot and this
is an interesting notation you should
notice here our axes 0 so 1 we've used
instead of you can just iterate through
them but they're just an array so it's
an array of 0 is still the axes of the
first axes out of - and we're gonna plot
X x squared X x cubed line with 2 so
we're gonna go ahead and just plot two
graphs right on top of each other
without doing multiple plots on here now
we'll set the grid equal to true on here
and let's go ahead and run that and you
can see here are two plots with the x
value going across and i'm gonna do
something similar and by the ways you
can just if you look at it you can see
the grid on there that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're going to take the same data for
axes one so we have our plot of X x
squared X and x cubed line with two and
this time we're going to take our axes
want and do Y limit it's actually set
underscore wide limit this is the y axes
this is going to be an array of two two
values will do 0 comma 60 I'm just
making these numbers up the guys in the
back actually made them up I'm just
using their numbers we're gonna set the
X limit
and let's set the X limit as don't
forget our brackets there 2 comma 5 so
it's the same day 2 going in and but
we're sitting a limit on it and let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit 0 to 60 so we're looking at just a
lower part of this curve here up to here
and we have the X limit 2 to 5 so that
starts right here at 2 and you can see
very different graphs this is kind of
nice because you could actually put one
of these on top of the other if you
wanted to draw focus to one part of a
graph remember how we did that earlier
one inside the other but just a quick
note you can easily limit your graph and
re kind of reshape the way it looks
quite easily and we can also add the
grid down there if you want a grid will
run that and add the grid in there
oops it's get to do the grid beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
make double check your order when you're
printing these things out but also ups
if I change it to one so in this case it
might not be the order I wonder if I'll
go back here is one there we go
so does matter the order in grid but you
can set the grid for easy viewing here
nice setup on there but you can see how
we can limit the data so let's start
looking at some other 2d graphs and make
the cell a markdown so we run it as a
nice pretty title to it let's go ahead
and create some data with an NP array I
will do 0 to 5 on here there we go
and let's look at for common graphs
we'll put them side-by-side so we'll do
a figure our axes equals plot subplots 1
for columns and then figure size
hopefully will fit nicely on here seems
to do pretty good on here
and I'll go and just run that since
we're in there run you'll see I have my
4 blank plots on here and we'll start
with axes of 0 let's set title and we
want this to be a scatter plot the
scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of 0
scatter easy-to-remember scatter a bunch
of plots on there we'll do our in we can
do X or in
let's go ahead and do AXYZ set title
scatter already did that we're just
going to do scatter
let's say you do it on there notice how
you create a scatterplot with simply
with the scatter control we'll do let's
do the variable X x + let's throw some
randomness in here usually scatter plots
or I have a lot of random numbers
connected to them that's why they do
them on there and so the bigger the X
gets the bigger the randomness so 0.25
times the randomness and what we should
end up down here is with the scatter
plot and you can see as you go up it
just kind of has some random numbers and
moves up and down the line but plus just
the points so if you remember from back
up here where we did marker this is
plotting basically just the marker so
it's a scatter plot probably less use is
a step plot so for X's 1 we'll go ahead
and do a step plot so you can see what
that looks like and this time I'll use
our end value instead of X we generated
that in value up here and so for this we
have in n times 2 or in squared n times
2n squared line with equals 2 and if we
run that it creates a nice step up let's
see so we've got a scatter plot we've
got a steps plot let's do a bar plot and
we'll use the same formula in N squared
alignment centered because you can have
them left or right with 0.5 and alpha if
you remember correctly that's how how
opaque it is let's see what that looks
like on there so we have some nice you
can see here a nice bar plot it should
look pretty similar to the step plot but
color it in then we can change the width
let's see what I was gonna do point 9
run and if we take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
Alpha we take the Alpha out two and run
that so you know you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center and
run that everything you really can't see
the shift on here cuz that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put it back in there there we go
alignment Center and alpha now I can't
say have hues the step craft very much
there's certain a certain I guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so I use histograms
Allah
especially in data science but this is
nice if you have very concrete objects
somebody how many people were yellow
Hat's
that kind of thing well if we're gonna
do that let's go ahead and do the last
one which I see a lot more in the
sciences certainly using the data
science but more like for mapping like
sub publication on solar flares and they
were discussing the energy and so
filling in the graph gives it a very
different luck so we can do the fill
between it's just like you think it'd be
its fill between but with a underscore
between them we'll do X and x squared
and X and X cubed and we'll do color
green and alpha again in case you had
other data you want to plot on there you
can see it forms a nice squared coming
up here and also if you look at the
bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between if you
remember from calculus this would be if
you had like a car motor and efficiency
they were talking about the efficiency
going up and the loss and you're looking
for the space or the area between the
two lines so you can see a nice visual
of that let's look at a few more basic
two dimensionals so we have our figure
figure size on here we're gonna do a
radar chart to be honest I've never used
to radar chart in business or in data
science I can't to find a reason to use
one now so the first line for doing a
radar chart we have to add axes and the
figure and with this this actually
creates our all this let's run it so you
see what it creates it creates a nice
looks like you're on a submarine and
you're tracking The Hunt for Red October
or something like that and it needs all
of these the polar is the fact that
we're doing polar coordinates zero zero
point six point six has to do with the
size if you take out any of these things
and run them you get just a box if you
take out the other half you pretty much
get nothing in there and if you change
these numbers and change them a little
bit you can see it gets bigger
they had point six on here I'll go ahead
and leave it as one cuz that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the heights and the width and then let's
create some data T equals NP line space
and this is 0 to 2 times NP times
if you remember that is the distance
across and we can generate a hundred
points so this is just a thing of data
we're putting together when you simply
do an ax plot and in this case is two T
comma T which would be a diagonal line
on a regular chart now we'll give it a
nice color equals blue and line width
equals three let's see what that looks
like
and we can see here a spiral coming out
remember this being just a diagonal line
on a regular chart what happens if we
take this and instead of T time point
five there we go and you can see it
slightly alters the way it spirals out
we could do T times two Spyros it a
little quicker so it's kind of just a
fun I've Nega said I've never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar no submarine kind
of looks like one of those or in an
airplane and none of this would be
complete if we didn't discuss histograms
oh my gosh do I use a histogram so much
and we'll use our numpy that we have set
as n P to generate looks like we have a
hundred thousand variables we're gonna
set equal to n and of course we create
our figure and our axes from subplots
one to figure size twelve fourteen so
we're gonna look at two different
variations of the histogram and we'll
set a title default histogram set our
title there and then this is simply hist
four histogram and we'll just go ahead
and put in our in in there and let me
run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what has gone on
here so we generated an array here of
data one thousand random arrays it looks
like they're mostly between minus four
and four and then it adds up each one it
says zero you have thirty five thousand
that are zero so that's what's most
common on here and we have twenty
thousand that are somewhere in this
range right here between the minus two
and well looks like 1 minus 2 and
somewhere between 0 and 1 there's 30,000
numbers so all this is saying is this is
how common these variables are and this
gives you this is point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram when you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your rate just like you did on the
graphs on there and then we're going to
do a cumulative detailed histogram and
all it is is a histogram just do that
and we set cumulative equal to true and
bins equal 50 and I really want to
highlight the cumulative equals true is
important but we can now choose how many
bins we have in the first one it kind of
selected them for us in this case I'm
gonna go ahead and run this and you'll
see it has printed it out for us and
here's our whoops must have missed oh
there we go
doesn't help that I put it over the old
one there we go okay so now you have
your default histogram and then we have
a cumulative histogram and we should
have 50 steps in there and let's just
find out if that's true not so much by
counting them I'm not going to count
them if you want to you can count them
let's just change it to 10 and see what
happens
and we see here we have now 10 counts of
that and we could set that for 5 and run
that and then we have our 5 on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too that looks just like I did
before
I think there's what 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
they have 8 different bins on here is
what the default came out of put that
back in there run and so now I should
look almost identical and it does and
then we can put the cumulative back in
see what that looks like with
accumulative and run that and we can see
how that shifts everything over and has
a slightly different look wait it shifts
it all to the right no it doesn't
actually shift it to the right it's
cumulative
so it's a total of the different
occurrences and so what that means is
like if you consider this like for the
year of rainfall we have like day 1 you
had a little bit of rain day 2 we have
more rain and so if you look at the
number this is a hundred thousand thirty
five thousand so it's the cumulative
detailed histogram of the occurrence as
it grows and rainfall is a good one
because that would be a cumulative
histogram of how much rain occurred
throughout the year and we're gonna look
at two more graphs we've already looked
at a bunch of them we looked at our
radar graph we've looked at scatter step
bar fill-in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
crease the size align the look the color
the Alpha setting so let's look at
contour maps just put that in there
there we go
draw a contour map and before we draw a
contour map we need to go ahead and
create data for it and if you have
contours your data is all going to have
three different values so let's go ahead
and create the data here we have our you
didn't put your mat plot library your
numpy so we have our numbers array we'll
import
mat plot CM and that's your color maps
so you have all these different color
maps you can look at there's like
hundreds of color maps and so if you
don't want to do your own color you can
even do your own color map they're
pretty diverse and of course our PLT
we're going to our pie plot and to
generate our different data we're gonna
create a delta 0.025 and we'll start
with X when we're going to create an
array between minus 3 and 3 and delta
increments of 0.025 and we'll have our y
we'll do something similar and then
we'll create our XY into a mesh grid
again these are all numpy commands so if
you're not familiar with these you'll
want to go back and review our numpy
tutorial and we'll do an exponential on
here minus x squared minus y squared for
our Z one will do a Z 2 so we have two
different areas and Z equals Z 1 minus Z
2 2 times 2 so we've created a number of
values here let me go ahead and run this
and let's plug that in so you can see
where those values are going so once
we've set these we're gonna create our
figure and our X from our PLT subplots
we're gonna create the variables CS and
this is going to be our contour so right
here CS is our contour surface and we're
feeding it XY and Z if you remember XY
we created as our x and y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print X and let's print Y and I always
like to do this when I'm working with
something this either is really
complicated in this case is what we're
looking at or you don't understand yet
so we've created a mesh grid we have XY
and when we're done with this we end
with here's our X in this set of values
and our Y so there's our X&Y coordinates
and then we've also created Z based on
our x and y so we have X capital X
capital y and capital Z's or three
components x and y being the coordinates
well Z is it's going to be our actual
height since we're doing a contour map
so we created our contour map from our
XY and z coordinates we want to go ahead
and put in a seat label maybe we want to
go ahead and do an title on here I'll
put that in our set title and this is a
contour there we go contour map and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like and you'll see we
generated a nice little contour map
there's different settings you can play
with on this but you can picture this
being you're on a mountain climb and
here we have a line that's represents 0
maybe that's sea level and then moving
on up you have your contours of 0.5 and
then minus 1 and different setups and
little Hills I guess if it's - that's
like a pit so I guess you're going down
into a pit at minus 5 and minus 1 when
on the other side you can see you're
going up in levels so here's a mountain
top and here's like a basin of some kind
and in data science this could represent
a lot of things this could also be
representing two different values and
maybe profits and loss I don't know if
I'd ever really do that as a contour map
but I'm sure you can be creative and
find something fun to do with a contour
map and then we're gonna look at one
last map which is the 3d map and those
are can be really important as a final
product because they can show so much
additional information that you can't
fit on two-dimensional graphs there we
go draw a 3d image so we're gonna import
from our MPL toolkits the implant 3d and
the axes 3d we're gonna import axes 3d
this is what's gonna let us work with
the 3d image and this should look
familiar we're gonna create another
figure just like we did before
figure size 14 by 6 it's a good fit on
the screen I'll go ahead and run that so
we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our X and we're gonna set that
equal to fig at subplot that should also
be familiar from earlier and we're going
to work with this sets the settings for
the projection we're going to use one
two one
projection 3d and we'll see what that
looks like in just a minute and we just
created some three-dimensional data here
before where we had X Y & Z capital X Y
& Z so we're going to reuse that data
we're just going to use that since this
also this is also a three dimensional
image so let's use that for a three
dimensional graph and we simply do a X
plot underscore surface and a capital X
capital y Capital Z so there's our data
coming in and we're gonna add some
settings in here we're gonna do our
stride for C stride for and line with
zero I'll show you what that is here in
just a minute let's go ahead and run
that so we can see our graph and of
course it helps if I don't add an extra
comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph so let's take a
little bit time to explore some of these
numbers we have going in here we have
the our stride for the C stride for and
the projection 3d projection 3d is the
important one because that's telling us
that this is a 3d graph here so what are
these first numbers 1 2 1 let's just
change one of these I'm going to change
this to 5 and it's gonna give me an
error let's change it to 1 and it didn't
work let's change this the middle 1 to 3
instead and you're gonna see how it
starts reshaping the size and how it
fits on the screen and it will change
the first one to 2 we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle I'll do seven on this
one there we go you can see it really
shifted it there but again that changes
the size now it fits on the canvas but
we'll leave it at the 1/2 and just so
you get a good look at what that we're
talking about here this is column width
and index from before if we do 1 1 1 you
can see that it now spreads it out all
the way across uses a whole set up on
there so this has to do with the size
and how big you want it to be now
there's one term that we didn't cover in
this yet but we've used it throughout
the whole set up and I'm just going to
that down here even though we're not
gonna go into detail and that's the term
heat mat you might see that is kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people still talk about heat maps
what is a heat map well it is simply a
color map that's all it is so if you
ever see the term heat map that refers
you to fact this is in different colors
representing different heights that one
is in the heat map but you can see up
here we switched into let me go back up
here here we go this one has different
colors for the different values a lot of
times you'll use like instead of X&Y you
might do a heat map where you have a
fourth value and the fourth value
represents the color and so you'll see
this 3d image in two nice colors
represented by a heat map that's all it
is so if you see the term heat map that
only means we're plotting some of the
data in color to make it stand out or to
give it a fourth dimension in this case
so we've covered a lot of things on mat
plot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
exam and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell cell type markdown
and run that so it looks pretty practice
example right a path python program to
create a pie chart of the popularity of
programming languages okay excellent and
if you're going to have a challenge we
need some data and I'll just throw in
our import our map plot library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're gonna have our languages
we're gonna have Python we're gonna Java
PHP JavaScript c-sharp C++ so those are
six categories and then we have our
popularity oops misspelling their
popularity will give the first one 22.2%
Java 17.6 and I don't know if these are
real numbers they pulled my guess is
that they might have just been made up
because I don't know pythons really that
much more popular than the other ones
maybe specific to data science because
python is very popular in data science
right now cuz it has so many options
the only other program that that's
highly used and exclusively for data
Sciences are so pythons big and Python
also just a lot more it's a full
programming language where R is
primarily for data science
they didn't put our in here so we have
Python we have Java our PHP and you can
see the different values that given it
or different percentages and I did add
these up does not add up to 100% it adds
up to 71% or something like that and
then we're gonna give colors and we've
chosen these guys in the back brought in
these colors I'm not sure what these
colors are we'll find out in a minute so
I'll be exciting but you can see they're
using the actual color values you can
pull off of a color wheel or something
like that you could have just as easily
done blue red green if you're too lazy
to pick the exact colors and then let's
go ahead and solve this and see we got
here we're gonna do something a little
fancy just because we can the first
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna use
variable called explode and you'll
notice that there's six variables in
here so that matches our six different
categories and the first one we've done
is 0.1 and then zero zero zero zero zero
point one when we put this in here under
the explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart and this is
simply PLT dot hi and we're plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pie not too
exciting there and then we'll go ahead
and put in all the extras I talked about
explode or we can explode one of the
values out so here's our explode equals
explode labels as languages because we
want to know what the different colors
mean here's our colors equals colors our
auto picture and this is standard print
format so that's a Python setup on there
and that's just gonna put the value on
the pie slice and then we're gonna add
shadow cuz it just looks cooler with a
shadow gives a little 3d look and we'll
do a start angle of a hundred and forty
let's go ahead and run this and take a
look and see what comes out of that and
look how that changes a whole set up so
here's our labels there's our value we
put on there there's our slice that's
pushed out and there's our shadow a 3d
effect and then we started at 140 we
could also rotate this lets
do this angle 90 and if we run it you'll
see the blue pie slices moved up a
little bit we could actually do is just
take the whole starting triangle out and
run he'll default to zero this is what
it looks like if it defaulted to zero so
depending on where you want the
highlighted slice to appear usually you
want that appear on the left because
people read left to right and so it
draws a focus on two in this case Python
and how great python is I'm a little
biased we're teaching a Python tutorial
so it should be understandable that
we're looking at Python and one last
reference before we close you can go
over to the mat plot library hype lot
setup and if you go underneath there the
different functions on there you can
look this up on their website you'll see
a full list and this is why it's so
important to go through a tutorial like
this because this list is just so
massive trying to figure out like here's
our bar plot there's a bar H you can add
Barb's there's a box plot we didn't
cover C labels all totally different
kind of for your contour plot you can
set up in there if you go down here we
have our figures we used on there we
showed you the basics how to do the
figure you'll see some closer references
on those there's a histogram down here H
is T there's also the hiss to D makes a
2d histogram plot H lines all of this
these are all the different commands
that are underneath of here and you can
see it's pretty extensive we've covered
all the basic ones so that you know have
a solid ground to look at these
different options so when you come to
these functions some of them are gonna
look a little off or not off will look
unfamiliar but you'll still have the
availability to probably understand most
of this and have a basic understanding
of your map plot library with that I'd
like to thank you for joining us today
for another step in your journey in
programming with Python and this part in
Met plot library for data science for
more information visit us at
www.nerdkits.com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here